wow it still would be really funny to
watch my dad
yeah this answer the internet is brought
to you by Roman swipes stick around
after for more details hey everybody I'm
Stevo and I'm here to answer the
internet does Wendy stay in the bedroom
with you during sex yep
she does and we have two dogs that have
to leave and two dogs that are allowed
to stay what what because well behaviors
are not over here no um it's all about
the the hunger for semen we have one dog
that is so utterly addicted to semen
that like as I'm doing it the dogs
literally jamming his nose I mean
straight up this dog loves comes so much
it's trying to get it straight from the
top
I mean I was literally trying to Bone
I've got the dogs to this nose up my ass
and that's not even that's not hyperbole
that's not exaggeration that dog has to
go yeah
100 if someone texts you a picture of
your dick with no context which you know
it's your dick
[Music]
I like to think so
you probably got some scars and see
[ __ ] some some things that stick out
I mean what I have is just straight bent
to the left because I'm right-handed
yeah my dick's like a Beyonce song
would you rather drink one sweat
cocktail every day or have to do shark
bait once a month
I'm gonna go with the sweat cocktail
even though candidly I did not drink
that sweat cocktail I was already
burping out before it even went in
I like this [ __ ]
but in all seriousness I really am um
I've lost my sense of humor for like
sharks
what's one stunt you would have to turn
down now one of my
not one of my most successful YouTube
video that I've put out in the last
couple years was 10 stunts I backed out
of
and uh the common theme is uh trying to
preserve my spinal cord and not be in a
wheelchair good man good yeah that's a
good one okay if you were to teach a
college course what would it be
man that's a good question what college
course would I teach the one a that I
got during my brief and my bad
experience in University of Miami was in
philosophy you could see that the only a
I ever gotten I think that's honestly me
too yeah
I got a real kick out of philosophy
about how we can we would be
we could more effectively prove that we
don't even exist then that we're even
here
would you rather throw up anytime
someone says McDonald's or wear a fedora
for the rest of your life and if anyone
asks you about it have to say I like the
way it looks that's good is this your
own game that you saw yeah [ __ ]
entrepreneurs man that's good because
that [ __ ] cards became Manatee great
concept but God is a bad execution yeah
we took it to the next level those
[ __ ] cards are dumb dude this this is
the next level I read that well this is
either us or all of our fans it's like
10 years of crowdsourcing good work you
know my answer to this question is good
job bar stool ah throw up anyone now I'm
going to go with B I'd rather Rock a
fedora and say that I like it because I
try not to throw up anymore bad for my
health
yeah
yeah
dude it's rad
would you rather watch your dad [ __ ] a
hundred year old man or watch your
mother kill someone
that's much better than Mary uh killer
ah
I mean dude you never want anybody to
get hurt
I don't want anyone to get well let's
say whoever she kills is tarot a
terrible person well it still would be
really [ __ ] funny to watch my dad
[ __ ] 100
yeah I think everyone else in the world
that we've done this with is like I
can't watch my dad [ __ ] 100.
I mean I mean dad you got to save
somebody's life
an opportunity to be a hero yeah if you
were gay for a day who would you want to
bang
I don't even think I would have to be
gay to want to bang Ryan Reynolds
right rods Brad Pitt to me is always the
[ __ ] guy yeah he's the gold standard
especially
like uh in the movie Seven
if you could pick one celebrity to
replace you on jackass who is it don't
do that to me man
Roman's webs are the most magical thing
that will ever enter your life all you
have to do is you get this box right
here right you take one of these very
discreetly marked you can pop this in
the wallet pop this in the pocket
doesn't matter take one of these take
your rip it open and then boom out you
come with a little hand sanitizer type
deal you wipe that on your peep you peep
or your penis right you get that in 2019
there was a study that showed it
increases time for sex time to orgasm by
four times four times longer you're
lasting in bed for your lady or your man
or whoever they're safe convenient it
will not transfer to your partner it
just stays on your peep your peep or
your penis and right now go to go to
getroman.com answer and you'll have 20
off your first order that's get
roman.com answer for 20 off your first
order if there were stats available at
the end of your life what's one
statistic about yourself you'd want to
know
oh I like that that's philosophical yeah
it's not but I feel like I want to take
this two directions one serious and
like one trivial
um I want to know do I actually hold the
world record for a bunch of categories
most selfies taken because like after
every single [ __ ] show for 11 years
on tour I took a photo with every single
audience member at every one of my shows
who wanted one and uh I uploaded them to
my website to send traffic to my website
I think I've taken more selfies than
anybody in the world I also think I may
have autographed more merchandise slash
memorabilia than anybody in the world
because it's all I [ __ ] do yeah
stevo.com you can buy all of the sign
[ __ ] at steambo.com and I'll never stop
signing it and I always keep it [ __ ]
stupid cheap
um and uh
another world record I mean I know I've
kicked more people in the nuts and been
I've had more people ask me to kick them
in the nuts
that'll just ask you oh my god daily
basis
I used to have the position like who am
I to dash someone's dreams
but but I've retired from not kicking
assistant
um now uh in a serious sense I would
love to know
um
uh how many
that on some level how much have I
helped animals like buying by not eating
I do eat seafood but like just by by
choosing not to eat animals sure sure
you know like like they're waiting is
there a way to quantify how much that's
helped the environment the you know the
animals like and then I I like that to
be my answer because I would like for
more people to think about how they
could help animals more
on a bummer
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out